en el vídeo pasado hablamos sobre los
bienes y servicios finales y cómo
calcular el producto interno bruto en un
período determinado
entonces recuerda empezamos desde cero
primero pusimos mano de obra tierra y
así obtuvimos el algodón en rama con un
valor de mercado de 10 dólares y después
con más mano de obra obtuvimos el hilo
de algodón con un valor de mercado de 20
y así seguimos hasta obtener el producto
final que son los pantalones de
mezclilla con un valor de mercado de 50
dólares vimos en el vídeo pasado que la
contribución al producto interno bruto
sólo será este producto final los
pantalones de mezclilla con un valor de
mercado de 50 dólares que es lo que las
personas están dispuestas a pagar por
ellos entonces no contaríamos todos
estos bienes intermedios pero ahora
quizás te preguntas bueno qué sucede si
todo esto no pasa en un año si su
periodo el periodo que tomamos no es de
un año entonces termina por ejemplo el
año termina justamente aquí así que
estamos pensando en un producto interno
bruto para un año podríamos pensarlo por
ejemplo para uno
de año a supongamos que el periodo en
cuestión termina aquí este es el período
1 y el otro es el periodo 2 estoy acá en
verde es el periodo 2 en el periodo 1
llegamos a el hilo de algodón con un
valor de mercado de 20 dólares en el
período 2 a los pantalones de mezclilla
con un valor de mercado de 50 dólares
entonces este por ejemplo pudo haber
sido un año es el año siguiente lo que
pasaría es que en el periodo 1 veríamos
a este bien el hilo esté bien intermedio
el cual está sentado en el inventario de
alguien y está listo para ser usado
diríamos que esta es la contribución al
producto interno bruto y lo
consideraríamos como una inversión
porque lo podemos usar a futuro para
crear más cosas así que en el período 1
la contribución final es de 20 dólares
20 dólares y en el período 2 la
contribución no va a ser de 50 dólares
es decir si vamos a llegar a un punto en
el que los pantalones valen 50 dólares
pero hay que ver que no estamos contando
doble los mismos 20 dólares del periodo
entonces lo que vamos a hacer para no
contar doble vez los 20 dólares cuando
teníamos ya el nuestro hilo de algodón
es que vamos a restar la contribución
del período 1 para que no se cuente
tanto en el período 1 como en el período
2 así que lo que puedes decir es que le
estamos restando el valor del mercado de
la entrada en el inicio de ese periodo
entonces dirías 50 menos 20 dólares lo
cual es igual a la contribución del
producto interno bruto quitándole esos
20 dólares y convirtiendo a un bien
final de 50 dólares por lo tanto la
contribución final en el período 2 era
de 30 dólares